ברוכים הבאים חזרה למחשוב קוונטי בפרקטיקה אני Olivia Lan והפרק השלישי של היום הולך להתמקד ב
ניסוי qaoa בסקאלה של utility אם הייתם איתנו מההתחלה ראיתם אותנו עוברים על
חומרת IBM Quantum המסגרת של דפוסי Qiskit וטכניקות מיטיגציית השגיאות העדכניות והמתקדמות ביותר ש
חוקרים ומפתחים משתמשים בהן כדי להגדיל את הסקאלה של circuit קוונטיים הרגשנו שזה ממש חשוב לתת לכם את כל ה
הקשר הזה ולהראות לכם את הכיוון שאליו הולכנו אבל עכשיו אין שום סיבה לחכות עוד כדי לראות את כל המידע הזה ב
פעולה עכשיו כמה דברים שכדאי לזכור לפני שמתחילים הכל הולך לעקוב אחרי המסגרת של דפוסי
Qiskit אז נעבור על השלבים האלה בסדר מספר אחד זה מיפוי הבעיה שניים אופטימיזציה של ה-circuit שלוש
הרצה עם Primitives וארבע עיבוד אחרי או ניתוח התוצאות נתחיל עם דוגמה קטנה יחסית
כדי שכולכם תוכלו הכי טוב לתפוס את השלבים האלה ואת המטרה שלהם ואז נדון בדוגמה דומה מאוד אבל הרבה
יותר גדולה כדי להראות לכם איך אפשר להגדיל את הבעיה לרמה של 100 qubit אני הולך לתת לכם את כל ה
כלים שיאפשרו לכם להתקדם אחרי ההרצאה הזו ולהריץ את הבעיה הזו באופן עצמאי ולבסוף זה לא הולך להיות
הדרכת קוד לא משנה כמה ננסה ככל שמתקדמים קוד מתיישן ומפסיק להיות נתמך אז אם בסוף
תצפו בסרטון הזה שנה אחרי שהוא עלה אני לא רוצה שתתקעו על התחביר שעשוי להשתנות קצת עם הזמן במקום זה תהיה
דיון מפורט על הלוגיקה והגדרת הבעיה עם זאת יש מחברת תרגול שמתאימה לסרטון
הזה שמצורפת בתיאור למטה לעקוב אחרי הקוד או לחזור אליו אחרי ש
תצפו בשיעור הזה ולהריץ אותו בעצמכם ייתן לכם את חווית הלמידה הכי טובה אז כתזכורת מהירה לא
כל הבעיות החישוביות מתאימות למחשוב קוונטי בעיות קלות וחישובים פשוטים לא צריכים לנצל
את הטכנולוגיה הזו כי מחשבים קלאסיים כבר מספיק טובים בלפתור אותן נכון ל-2024 שלושת
התחומים שאנחנו הכי אופטימיים לגביהם הם סימולציה של טבע עיבוד נתונים עם מבנה
מורכב ולבסוף אופטימיזציה בעיות אופטימיזציה הן מהבעיות החישוביות הכי קשות
לפתור ביעילות בבעיית אופטימיזציה אתם מחפשים את הערך הגדול או הקטן ביותר האפשרי
עבור פונקציית עלות נתונה אבל עבור בעיות רבות שמעניינות אותנו מציאת הקיצון הזה הופכת להיות קשה באופן אקספוננציאלי
עם גודל הבעיה לכן זה הופך להיות כל כך קשה לחשב לדוגמה אתם יכולים לדמיין כמה
קשה יכול להיות לחשב מסלולי טיסה אופטימליים או מסלולי משלוח ברחבי המדינה בשיעור הזה אנחנו הולכים
לחקור בעיית אופטימיזציה מסוימת שנקראת Max cut שאותה נפתור באמצעות אלגוריתם
קוונטי שנקרא אלגוריתם אופטימיזציה קוונטי של קירוב או qaoa אז מה זו בעיית ה-Max cut
בעיית חיתוך מקסימלי היא סוג של בעיית אופטימיזציה קומבינטורית שמוגדרת על גרף שבה המטרה היא
לחלק את הקודקודים של הגרף לשתי קבוצות כך שמספר הקשתות בין שתי הקבוצות יהיה
מקסימלי אז למשל בגרף הזה כאן כל צומת מחובר ככה וה-Max cut מוצג בקו המתפתל
הזה שמחלק את הצמתים לקבוצה הסגולה ולקבוצה האפורה הדרך לעשות את זה על ידי חציית המספר הגדול ביותר
של קשתות אפשרי היא לחתוך דרך חמש קשתות לגרף הזה כאן כיוון שהגרף כל כך קטן
זה לא קשה לנסות כמה חיתוכים אפשריים על נייר או אפילו בראש ולהבין שחמש זה הפתרון הכי טוב
אפשרי אבל תדמיינו אם מספר הצמתים הוכפל ואז שולש מהר מאוד זה הופך לבלתי אפשרי לעשות
ביד ואחרי מספר מסוים זה הופך להיות כל כך מסובך שגם מחשבי על מתקשים להחזיר באופן אמין את התשובה הטובה ביותר וזה בגלל ש
מספר החיתוכים המקסימלי גדל באופן אקספוננציאלי עם מספר הצמתים אמנם זה עשוי להיראות קצת מופשט
אבל יש הרבה בעיות מהעולם האמיתי שאפשר להמיר לבעיית Max cut כמו זיהוי הונאות בפיננסים אשכול
גרפים עיצוב רשתות ועיצוב VLSI וגם ניתוח מדיה חברתית ה
דוגמה של מדיה חברתית קלה במיוחד להבנה נניח שאתם רוצים למצוא קבוצה של אנשים שיש להם הכי הרבה
קשרים אפשריים לאנשים אחרים בפלטפורמת מדיה חברתית כדי לזהות משתמשי כוח או אנשים ש
יש להם הכי הרבה השפעה בקבוצה חברות בפועל מנסות לעשות את זה לעתים קרובות נקודה אחרונה כאן ה-Max cut הוא לעתים קרובות
תת-שגרה של בעיה גדולה יותר אז זה אולי לא מגדיר את האפליקציה עצמה אבל משמש מתחת לפני השטח זה
נפוץ הרבה יותר ממה שאולי תחשבו באופן נאיבי עכשיו הגיע הזמן להתחיל ה
שלב הראשון הוא ליצור את הגרף שלנו אפשר לעשות את זה על ידי ייבוא חבילת Python שנקראת rust Works להגדיר כמה
צמתים אתם עובדים איתם על ידי ציון המספר n ואז להוסיף את הצמתים לגרף G תצטרכו גם
לצייר את הקשתות שלכם נעשה את זה ביד כאן פשוט על ידי פירוט שלהן במערך ככה שבו מציגים את המספר האחרון
שמציין את המשקל של הקשת או כמה חזק שני הצמתים המצוינים מחוברים כאן אנחנו פשוט
הולכים להישאר עם משקל של אחד לכולם אבל אולי תהנו לשחק עם המשקל מאוחר יותר ולראות איך הפתרון
משתנה כדי לקבל תחושה של מה המשנה של משקל בהקשר הזה בואו נחזור לדוגמת המדיה החברתית שלנו אתם יכולים לחשוב
על המשקל הזה בתור כמה משפיע אדם אחד עשוי להיות על אחר הקשר שלכם לבן או בת הזוג או קרוב משפחה
למשל כנראה יקבל משקל גבוה יותר ממישהו שהוא סתם מכר עכשיו ציירו את הגרף שלכם ה
מחברת המצורפת תראה לכם את התחביר הנכון קודם כל לפני שנשקול איך
למפות את הבעיה הזו ל-circuit קוונטי בואו נבנה קצת הקשר לגבי איך בעיית ה-Max cut הופכת לבעיית אופטימיזציה
מלכתחילה אנחנו מתחילים בלשקול את המינימיזציה של פונקציה f של x כאשר הקלט X הוא וקטור
n-ממדי שהרכיבים שלו מתאימים לכל צומת בגרף נתייחס לפונקציה הזו מעכשיו
כפונקציית העלות שלנו ואז אנחנו צריכים להגביל כל אחד מהרכיבים האלה להיות אפס או
אחד כאן כלומר בצד אחד של החיתוך או בצד השני אפשר לכתוב פונקציה בתור
זוג צמתים x i ו-XJ שאומרת לנו האם הקשת המתאימה נמצאת בחיתוך כלומר פלוס הכמות x i פלוס XJ
מינוס x i כפול XJ מזהה האם הקשת בחיתוך אם הכמות הזו שווה
לאחד זה אומר שהקשת בחיתוך אחרת זה אפס והקשת לא בחיתוך הבעיה של מציאת
מספר הקשתות המקסימלי בחיתוך אפשר אז לנסח כמקסימיזציה של הפונקציה הזו הלאה אנחנו בעצם הולכים
להוסיף סימן מינוס גלובלי לפונקציה הזו מה שהופך את הבעיה החדשה לשקולה למציאת המינימום של הפונקציה הזו
במקום וכך המינימום של f של x במקרה הזה יהיה כאשר מספר הקשתות שהחיתוך חוצה הוא
מקסימלי בחרנו לנסח את הבעיה כבעיית מינימיזציה כי זה מאפשר לנו אחר כך למפות אותה לבעיית מינימיזציית
אנרגיה כלומר מציאת מצב היסוד שזה מה שמחשבים קוונטיים באופן טבעי ממש טובים בו
אבל זכרו שאין כאן שום דבר שקשור למחשוב קוונטי עדיין אנחנו עדיין צריכים לנסח מחדש את הבעיה הזו ל
משהו שמחשב קוונטי יכול להבין עכשיו אנחנו מוכנים להיכנס לעובי הקורה ולהתחיל את העבודה וה
שלב הראשון הוא למפות את הבעיה ל-circuit קוונטי אולי לא ברור איך אנחנו
הולכים לעבור מגרף כמו זה שציירנו ל-circuit קוונטי אבל בואו ניקח את זה לאט זכרו שאנחנו
הולכים לנסות לפתור את בעיית ה-Max cut הזו באמצעות qaoa באלגוריתם qaoa בסופו של דבר אנחנו רוצים שיהיה לנו אופרטור
ההמילטוניאן שישמש לייצוג פונקציית העלות של הבעיה שלנו וכן circuit עם פרמטרים
האנזץ או מצב הניסיון שנשתמש בו כדי לייצג מצבים קוונטיים שהם ניחושים מושכלים או מועמדים
לפתרון הבעיה אנחנו יכולים לדגום ממצבים מועמדים אלה ואז להעריך אותם
באמצעות פונקציית העלות במקרה הזה פונקציית העלות היא f של x אבל אנחנו צריכים לבטא אותה באופן
שמרגיש טבעי למחשב הקוונטי בשביל זה ננצל סדרה של טרנספורמציות
מתמטיות כדי לבטא את f של x כפונקציית אנרגיה ההמילטוניאן השלב הראשון של
התהליך הוא לבטא את הבעיה של מינימיזציה של f של x כבעיית אופטימיזציה בינארית ריבועית ללא אילוצים
או QUBO בקיצור QUBO היא דרך כללית לנסח בעיות אופטימיזציה קומבינטוריות כאלה
כאן Q היא מטריצה N על N של מספרים ממשיים N מתאים למספר
הצמתים בגרף שלנו חמישה בדוגמה הזו ו-X הוא אותו וקטור של משתנים בינאריים מהניסוח
ההתחלתי כדי להריץ את אלגוריתם ה-qaoa ביעילות אנחנו צריכים לבטא את בעיית האופטימיזציה שלנו במונחים של
המילטוניאן שהוא אופרטור מתמטי שמייצג את האנרגיה הכוללת של מערכת ספציפית אנחנו רוצים
ליצור המילטוניאן של פונקציית עלות שיש לו את התכונה שאנרגיית מצב היסוד שלו או ערך עצמי מינימלי
מתאים למינימום של הפונקציה שמקודדת את מספר החיתוכים המקסימלי בגרף G ברגע ש
יש לנו את ההמילטוניאן הזה כל מה שאנחנו צריכים לעשות כדי לפתור את בעיית האופטימיזציה הוא להכין את מצב היסוד של ההמילטוניאן על המחשב הקוונטי ואז
דגימה ממצב זה תיתן בהסתברות גבוהה את הפתרון למינימיזציה של f של X כפי שמתברר
יש לנו מזל כי בעיית ה-QUBO קשורה מאוד ובעצם שקולה חישובית ל
אחד מההמילטוניאנים המפורסמים והנפוצים ביותר בפיזיקה המילטוניאן אייזינג כדי לכתוב את בעיית ה-QUBO
כהמילטוניאן אייזינג הזה כל מה שאנחנו צריכים לעשות זה החלפת משתנים פשוטה כדי לעבור מ
משתנים בוליאניים 0 ו-1 למשתני ספין מינוס אחד ואחד השלב הזה הוא
ישיר הוא מוצג ביותר פירוט בנספח של המחברת המצורפת למי שמעוניין אבל בסוף המינימיזציה של ביטוי ה-QUBO
הזה זהה למינימיזציה של הביטוי הזה כותבים מחדש שוב קצת ו
יש לנו את המילטוניאן פונקציית העלות שבו המינימום של הביטוי מייצג את מצב היסוד ו-Z
הופך לאופרטור Pauli בעוד B הוא מקדם סקלרי ממשי עכשיו שיש לנו את ההמיל
טוניאן פשוט לכתוב אותו מחדש במונחים של אופרטורי Pauli ZZ לוקליים שיומרו בקלות ל
gate של שני qubit ב-circuit הקוונטי שלנו עיינו במחברת המשויכת כדי לראות איך זה נעשה אבל הפלט
מוצג בשורה הזו כאן שימו לב שבדוגמה שלנו יש
שישה אובייקטים או מחרוזות Pauli כי כל אחד מייצג קשת בגרף אורך המחרוזת תואם למספר
הצמתים אז I I I ZZ זה חמישה צמתים והמחרוזת תהיה מורכבת מ
יחידות בכל המיקומים חוץ מהאינדקסים של הצמתים המעורבים בקשת שיכילו איברי Z ב-Qiskit
מחרוזות ביטים שמייצגות qubit ממוספרות הפוך לדוגמה קשת בין צמתים 0 ו-1 תקודד כ
I I I ZZ עם ההמילטוניאן כתוב במונחים של Pauli אנחנו מוכנים לבנות את
ה-circuit הקוונטי שלנו ה-circuit הקוונטי הזה יעזור לנו לדגום פתרונות טובים מהמחשב הקוונטי אלגוריתם ה-qaoa
מושפע מהמשפט האדיאבטי שקובע שאם נתחיל במצב היסוד של המילטוניאן תלוי זמן
ואם ההמילטוניאן מתפתח מספיק לאט ובהינתן מספיק זמן המצב הסופי יהיה מצב היסוד
של ההמילטוניאן הסופי qaoa אפשר לחשוב עליו כגרסת טרוטר הדיסקרטית של האלגוריתם
האדיאבטי הקוונטי שבו כל שלב טרוטר מייצג שכבה שנקרא לה P אז
במקום להתפתח ממצב אחד לאחר בכל שכבה של P נעבור הלוך ושוב בין המילטוניאן
פונקציית העלות שלנו לבין משהו שנקרא המילטוניאן המערבב שלנו שנשמע עליו עוד קצת עוד רגע אבל הנקודה שאני רוצה להעביר
היא ש-qaoa יש לו את היתרון של להיות מהיר יותר מהאלגוריתם האדיאבטי הקוונטי אבל הוא מחזיר פתרונות
מקורבים ולא את האופטימלי בגבול שבו מספר השכבות שואף לאינסוף qaoa מתכנס למקרה האדיאבטי
אבל כמובן שזה מאוד יקר חישובית כדי ליצור את ה-circuit הקוונטי שלנו
נחיל אופרטורים מתחלפים כאן עם פרמטרים של gamma ו-beta אשר
ייצגו את הדיסקרטיזציה של אבולוציית הזמן אז שוב שלושת החלקים העיקריים
של circuit ה-qaoa הם אחד מצב הניסיון ההתחלתי באפור שהוא מצב היסוד
של המערבב מהמצב האדיאבטי של האבולוציה שנוצר על ידי הפעלת gate Hadamard על כל qubit שניים
אבולוציית פונקציית העלות שכבר יש לנו בסגול כהה ושלוש האבולוציה תחת המילטוניאן
המערבב שעליו עוד לא דיברנו בסגול בהיר עכשיו ההמילטוניאן ההתחלתי שלנו נקרא
המערבב כי מצב היסוד שלו הוא סופרפוזיציה של כל מחרוזות הביטים האפשריות שמעניינות ולכן
מאלץ תערובת של כל הפתרונות האפשריים בהתחלה המילטוניאן המערבב הוא סכום פשוט של פעולות Pauli X
על כל צומת בגרף Qiskit מאפשר לכם להשתמש באופרטור מערבב מותאם אישית שונה אם תרצו אבל
במקרה הזה פשוט נשתמש בסטנדרטי אז שוב אפשר לראות שעם Qiskit הרבה מהעבודה מוסרת
עבורנו מה שהופך את מציאת המילטוניאן המערבב ומצב ההתחלה לטריוויאלי העבודה היחידה שהיינו צריכים לעשות היא
למצוא את פונקציית העלות כל איטרציה של האופרטורים האלה נקראת שכבה אפשר לראות שכבות אלה כ
דיסקרטיזציות של אבולוציית הזמן של המערכת כפי שתואר קודם הדפוס המתחלף מגיע מ
פירוק טרוטר ומקרב את הפונקציות האקספוננציאליות של מטריצות לא-קומוטטיביות באופן כללי ככל שיותר שכבות או
צעדים נכלול ככה נהיה קרובים יותר לאבולוציית זמן רציפה אז בתיאוריה ככל שהתוצאה תהיה מדויקת יותר
אבל בדוגמה הזו נתחיל בדגימה עם שתי שכבות בלבד זכרו שגם המילטוניאן פונקציית העלות וגם
המערבב הם עם פרמטרים אנחנו עדיין צריכים למצוא ערכים אופטימליים ל-gamma ול-
beta עכשיו אני מכיר בכך שזה היה המון מידע ואם אתם רואים את סוג המתמטיקה הזה בפעם הראשונה זה יכול להיות מסובך למזלנו אחד מהדברים המדהימים
ב-Qiskit הוא שהרבה ממה שעברנו עליו אפשר לעשות אוטומטית בלי מאמץ רב מהמשתמש טוב להבין מה
קורה מאחורי הקלעים במיוחד כשמגדילים לניסויים יותר גדולים אבל לא תצטרכו לעשות את כל העבודה הזו
ביד כל פעם מחדש עכשיו מיפינו את הבעיה שלנו ל-circuit קוונטי זו הייתה קצת עבודה
אבל אל דאגה זה הופך לקל יותר ואינטואיטיבי יותר ככל שעושים את זה יותר עכשיו אנחנו מוכנים לעבור לשלב שניים
אופטימיזציה של ה-circuit שלנו לחומרה אז בעוד שה-circuit שיצרנו נראה די פשוט והוא
שימושי לבניית הבנה אינטואיטיבית זכרו שהשבב הקוונטי לא מבין מה הבלוק המופשט
הזה אנחנו צריכים להפוך אותו לסדרה של gate של qubit אחד ושניים שהם ילידים לחומרה וכשאני
אומר ילידים אני מתכוון שזה ישוכתב למה שאפשר לבצע ישירות על ה-qubit circuit כאלה
נחשבים ככתובים בארכיטקטורת סט ההוראות של ה-backend שאולי תראו בקיצור כ-circuit ISA
מודול ה-transpiler של Qiskit SDK מציע סדרה של מעברי טרנספילציה שיכולים
לבצע מגוון רחב של טרנספורמציות circuit אנחנו רוצים לוודא שה-circuit שלנו מותאם ל
מטרה שלנו נזכיר מהשיעור הקודם שלנו שתהליך הטרנספילציה כולל מספר שלבים מיפוי
ה-qubit ב-circuit או משתני ההחלטה ל-qubit פיזיים על המכשיר פריסה של ההוראות ב
circuit הקוונטי להוראות ילידות לחומרה שה-backend באמת מבין ניתוב של כל
qubit ב-circuit שמתקשרים ישירות ל-qubit פיזיים שהם צמודים אחד ל
שני וכמו תמיד פרטים נוספים על זה אפשר למצוא בדף התיעוד
עכשיו מגיע שלב מרגש שבו נבחר על איזה backend להריץ את ה-circuit שלנו בעצם אנחנו צריכים לעשות את זה
לפני שלב הטרנספילציה כי ה-transpiler מבצע אופטימיזציה שונה למעבדים שונים זו עוד סיבה למה זה
חשוב ש-Qiskit יכול לבצע אוטומטית כל כך הרבה מהשלב הזה לא הייתם רוצים לבצע אופטימיזציה ל-circuit שלכם ביד
שאפשר לעשות אבל לפעמים זה מסובך ולוקח הרבה זמן רק כדי לגלות שאתם בעצם רוצים להריץ
את ה-circuit על מעבד אחר עם תכונות שונות ואז תצטרכו לעשות את כל העבודה הזו שוב העבירו
את ה-backend שבחרתם דרך פונקציית ה-transpiler ואל תשכחו לציין את רמת האופטימיזציה הפעם
בחרתי ברמת אופטימיזציה שלוש שהיא הגבוהה והמקיפה ביותר ברמת
אופטימיזציה וזה בעצם הכל בשביל שלב שניים ה-circuit שלי עבר טרנספילציה אוטומטית וציירתי אותו כאן כדי ש
תוכלו לראות איך הוא תורגם ל-gate של qubit אחד ושניים עכשיו הגיע הזמן לשלב שלוש
הרצת ה-circuit עם Primitives של Qiskit עד כה ביצענו טרנספילציה ל-circuit והשארנו את הפרמטרים gamma ו-
beta בלי לגעת אבל אנחנו לא יכולים באמת להריץ את ה-circuit בלי לציין את הערך של הפרמטרים האלה בזרימת העבודה של qaoa
הפרמטרים האופטימליים של qaoa נמצאים בלולאת אופטימיזציה איטרטיבית שבה מריצים סדרה של הערכות
circuit ומשתמשים באופטימייזר קלאסי כדי למצוא את הפרמטרים האופטימליים של beta ו-gamma אבל אנחנו צריכים להתחיל
ממשהו אז הטמעתי כמה ניחושים התחלתיים ל-Gamma 1 gamma 2 ו-beta 1 beta 2 של Pi חלקי 2 ו-Pi
בהתאמה אני גם רוצה שתשימו לב שנשתמש באופטימייזר כדי למצוא פתרונות טובים יותר ל-gamma ו-Beta
ומכיוון שאני מחשב רק שתי שכבות כרגע זה כל מה שאני צריך אבל אם תבנו circuit qaoa מדויק יותר
תכללו יותר שכבות ולכן תצטרכו gamma ו-beta מותאמים לכל שכבה
ברצף עכשיו בואו נעצור לרגע ונזכור את האפשרויות שלנו ל-Primitives יש לנו את ה-estimator ואת
ה-sampler במה לדעתכם נשתמש לסוג כזה של עבודה ובכן לא משנה מה ניחשתם
אתם בעצם צודקים אנחנו הולכים להשתמש גם ב-estimator וגם ב-sampler ללולאת האופטימיזציה ההתחלתית
נצטרך את ה-estimator אבל נשתמש ב-sampler מאוחר יותר לקריאת הפתרון
הסופי עכשיו אנחנו כמעט מוכנים להריץ את האלגוריתם שלנו אני מבטיח אבל מהר מאוד חשוב לציין שאפשר
לשלוח את העבודה שלכם במגוון דרכים שונות שנקראות מצבי הרצה קודם כל יש לנו מצב עבודה בקשת
primitive בודדת של estimator או sampler שנעשית בלי מנהל הקשר circuit וקלטים ארוזים כבלוקים מאוחדים
של primitive שנקראים PUB ומוגשים כמשימת הרצה על המחשב
הקוונטי מצב אצווה הוא מנהל עבודות מרובות להרצה יעילה של ניסוי שמורכב מהרבה
עבודות עצמאיות השתמשו במצב אצווה כדי להגיש מספר עבודות primitive בו זמנית מצב סשן חלון
ייעודי להרצת עומס עבודה מרובה עבודות זה מאפשר למשתמשי פרימיום להתנסות באלגוריתמים וריאציוניים באופן
צפוי יותר ואפילו להריץ מספר ניסויים בו זמנית תוך ניצול המקביליות של
הסטאק השתמשו בסשנים לזרימות עבודה איטרטיביות וניסויים שדורשים גישה ייעודית לניסוי qaoa
סשן יהיה בחירה טובה להתקדם איתה אם יש לכם גישה אליו כיוון שתצטרכו לנסות מספר circuit לערכים שונים של beta
ו-gamma אוקיי עכשיו בואו נחזור לבעיית האופטימיזציה שלנו כבר
הגדרנו את המילטוניאן פונקציית העלות HC וזרימת העבודה המלאה היא כזו אלגוריתם ה-qaoa
מתחיל באתחול ה-qubit במצב סופרפוזיציה ואז מחיל את האנזץ עם P שכבות הוא
מאתחל פרמטרים של gamma ו-beta ואז מריץ את ה-circuit באמצעות ה-estimator primitive ברגע שנחשב
את ערכי התוחלת נשתמש באופטימייזר של scipi שנקרא COBYLA COBYLA
מבצע אופטימיזציה של פונקציית העלות באופן קלאסי מחוץ ל-QPU ברגע שהערכים של gamma ו-beta עודכנו אנחנו
חוזרים על זה נעשה את זה עד שהערך של פונקציית העלות הכוללת יתכנס ויגיע לערך הנמוך ביותר
ואז נבחר את הערכים של gamma ו-beta שמתאימים לערך העלות הנמוך הזה ונריץ את ה-circuit פעם אחרונה
עכשיו באמצעות ה-sampler זו התוצאה של הרצת אופטימייזר COBYLA עם הניחושים ההתחלתיים שלי כאן אתם יכולים לראות
שהערך של פונקציית העלות לאורך האיטרציות שבוצעו מתחיל קצת מטורלל והוא עולה ויורד אבל
אז הוא מתייצב על ערך נמוך נשתמש בערכי gamma ו-beta האחרונים שמתאימים לערך המינימלי של פונקציית העלות
כדי להריץ את ה-circuit פעם אחרונה ולדגום את מחרוזת הביטים שתיתן לנו את ה-Max
cut עכשיו באמצעות הערכים המותאמים שלנו ל-gamma ו-beta נריץ את ה-circuit פעם אחרונה כדי למצוא את מחרוזת
הביטים הכי טובה באמצעות ה-sampler פירטתי את הערכים הספציפיים שאני משתמש בהם כאן אבל זכרו כשאתם מנסים
את זה בעצמכם או אפילו סתם מריצים מחדש את אותה מחברת תרגול הערכים עשויים להשתנות קצת עכשיו נריץ
את ה-circuit המותאם שלנו עם הערכים האלה ונמצא את הפתרון המועמד לבעיית ה-Max cut שלנו אם השתמשתם
בסשנים זה כבר לא נחוץ כי אנחנו פשוט מריצים עבודה אחרונה אחת עכשיו סוף סוף נסתכל על
שלב העיבוד שלאחר ומציאת הפתרון הסופי שלנו קודם כל בואו נצייר את כל
השילובים האפשריים של צמתים שהמרנו למחרוזות ביטים כהיסטוגרמה אתם יכולים לראות מיד ש
כשהרצתי את זה מצאתי ארבעה פתרונות וסימנתי אותם בסגול שהם יותר סבירים מכל פתרון אחר
מחרוזת הביטים הגבוהה ביותר ולכן הכי סבירה היא 0 1 0 1 שימו לב שסדר ה-qubit
הפוך בגרף כשמסתכלים על הפתרון הכי סביר נשים לב שצמתים 0 ושלוש מקובצים ביחד
ובאופן דומה צמתים 1 2 וארבע אנחנו סוף סוף יכולים לצייר את מחרוזת הביטים הכי סבירה
חזרה כגרף וזכרו מחרוזת הביטים פשוט מתאימה למספרי הצמתים ואם הם כלולים
מסומנים באחד או לא כלולים מסומנים באפס בקיבוץ שלנו כשאנחנו מציירים את החיתוך עכשיו אנחנו יכולים לראות בעיניים את
הקו המקורב לחיתוך הטוב ביותר שפשוט מייצג את הקיבוץ האידיאלי של כל חמשת הצמתים שציירתי כאן דבר
אחד שאני רוצה להקדיש קצת זמן לדון בו כאן הוא העובדה שהפתרון הנכון אינו יחיד
בגלל הסימטריה של הגרף הזה יש מספר פתרונות נכונים במקום שצמתים 0 ושלוש יהיו
בתוך החיתוך אפשר שצמתים 2 וארבע יהיו כלולים ואתם יכולים לראות שכל מה שהייתי צריך לעשות זה לסובב את החיתוך כדי
לכלול את הנקודות החדשות האלה הפתרון של חמש נשאר אותו דבר
בואו נסתכל שוב על ההיסטוגרמה וארבעת הפתרונות הכי סבירים לרגע שני הפתרונות האחרונים הם
אלה שציירנו זה עתה והם נכונים באותה מידה אבל זה לא הכל אפשר גם להפוך את הצבעים לכל
הפתרונות הנכונים והפעם אנחנו פשוט חושבים על הצמתים בתור בתוך לעומת מחוץ לחיתוך ב
שקף הקודם זיהינו שני פתרונות נכונים ייחודיים אבל יש בעצם עוד שני פתרונות אחד שמתאים ל
ההפך של כל אחד מהם ראו איך כאן שבו ציירתי את שני הפתרונות הנותרים כל מה שעשיתי זה להפוך את
הצבעים עכשיו הבעיה היחידה היא שהאלגוריתם בעצם לא מצא או זיהה את הפתרון הרביעי האחרון הזה בתור
אחד מארבעת התשובות הכי סבירות הוא היה החמישי הפתרון הרביעי שהאלגוריתם זיהה
הוא בעצם לא נכון ואם הייתם מציירים אותו הייתם רואים שלפתרון הזה יש רק ארבעה חיתוכים ומכיוון שלאחרים
יש חמישה וארבע זה ברור פחות מחמש זה כמובן שגוי הנקודה כאן
היא שזה אלגוריתם מקורב הוא לא חסין מטעויות והוא לא נכון 100% מהזמן אתם צריכים
להפעיל קצת מהידע וההבנה שלכם כדי לבדוק שפיות של הפתרונות שווה להדגיש ש
השגיאה הזו יכולה לנבוע מכמה מקומות זה יכול להיות האופי המקורב של האלגוריתם עצמו ומספר
השכבות הקטן שבחרתי להשתמש בו זו יכולה להיות שגיאת דגימה סופית ואפשר להקטין אותה אם אגדיל את
מספר הירייות בניסוי שלי או שזו יכולה להיות שגיאת קריאה כיוון שהפתרון האמיתי הרביעי שונה רק בביט אחד
הסיבה שאני מציין את כל האפשרויות האלה היא כי זה מה שנדרש כדי להפוך באמת למומחה
של מחשוב קוונטי אתם צריכים להבין את הביצועים של החומרה ואיך זה יכול לתרום
לסוגים מסוימים של שגיאות ואיך לתקן אותן אבל בואו לא נשכח ש
היו 32 פתרונות אפשריים של מחרוזות ביטים ושארבעת הפתרונות האמיתיים נכללו בחמשת המועמדים הטובים ביותר
ואני השתמשתי רק בשתי שכבות כדי למצוא את זה באופן כללי אם אני רוצה להגדיל את הסיכויים שלי למצוא את
ה-Max cut הטוב ביותר בכל פעם הייתי מגדיל את עומק השכבות יש כמה דקויות בזה אבל זה לפרק
אחר עכשיו אני הולך לתת לכם לנסות את זה בעצמכם אבל הפעם אתם הולכים להשתמש ב-100
qubit אז אם נתחיל בציור הגרף של 100 qubit שלנו אתם יכולים לראות שזה כבר לא פשוט ואפילו לא אפשרי
לנסות לראות בעין איפה ה-Max cut יהיה יש פשוט יותר מדי אפשרויות כדי לבחור את זה ביד אבל
לפתור את הבעיה הזו באמצעות qaoa זה עדיין לגמרי אפשרי ואתם יכולים לעקוב אחרי בדיוק אותה זרימת עבודה שהשתמשנו בה ל-5
qubit אני עומד לשלוח אתכם בדרככם ולהטיל עליכם לנסות לעשות את הניסוי הזה אבל לפני כן בואו
נסכם זכרו ששישת השלבים של כל עבודת qaoa הם כדלקמן אחד הגדרת
המילטוניאן עלות כך שמצב היסוד שלו מקודד את הפתרון לבעיית האופטימיזציה שניים הגדרת
המילטוניאן מערבב שלוש בניית האופרטורים שמתאימים להמילטוניאנים
המוגברים ארבע בניית ה-circuit הוא יורכב ממצב היסוד ההתחלתי של המערבב ושכבות מתחלפות
חוזרות של פונקציית העלות והאבולוציה תחת המילטוניאנים המערבבים חמש הכנת מצב התחלתי ו
שימוש בטכניקות מחשוב קלאסי כדי לבצע אופטימיזציה של הפרמטרים שש הרצת ה-circuit מדידת מחרוזות ביטים של פלט
חיפוש הפתרון הכי סביר עכשיו כמה דברים לשים לב אליהם כאן אני
השתמשתי ברמת אופטימיזציה שלוש לדוגמה של 5 qubit שלי אבל אולי זה לא היה הכרחי והתשובה הנכונה עדיין יכולה
להתקבל רוב הזמן ברמת אופטימיזציה נמוכה יותר כי עומק ה-circuit היה נמוך יחסית למקרה של 5
qubit אבל ל-100 qubit ועומק circuit גדול כמעט בוודאות תצטרכו את הרמה הגבוהה ביותר של
אופטימיזציה כדי למצוא את התשובה הנכונה גם כדאי לזכור שאחד החלקים המאתגרים ביותר של זרימת עבודה טיפוסית בסקאלת
utility הוא שלב המיפוי ומציאת גרף שמתאים היטב לטופולוגיית heavy hex של IBM אם הייתם
עושים את העבודה הזו מאפס זה בלי ספק המקום שהייתם מקדישים לו הרבה מהזמן שלכם לעת עתה החלק הזה נעשה
בשבילכם כי זו לא הנקודה המרכזית של התרגיל הזה אבל קחו בחשבון שזה משהו שנצטרך
לתרגל והרצת עבודה בסקאלה גדולה זה לא תמיד פשוט כמו שנראה נצלול לזה יותר לעומק
בפרק 4 ה-circuit הסופי שלכם כמובן ייראה הרבה יותר מבולגן מה-circuit שרץ על 5 qubit
אבל מצד שני אני מרגיש שלהסתכל על ה-circuit הזה ולראות כמה gate יש בו ולדעת שיש לכם
את היכולת להריץ את זה על מעבדים קוונטיים אמיתיים זה די
מרשים וזה היה הפתרון הסופי שלי אתם יכולים לראות שהאלגוריתם בהחלט מסוגל לקבץ את הצמתים
האלה לשתי קבוצות שכביכול מזהות את ה-Max cut הטוב ביותר שמחלק אותם המעבר משתי הקבוצות
לקו ה-Max cut עצמו הוא טריוויאלי בכל מקום שהצבע משתנה לאורך הקווים שמחברים את הצמתים מציין
איפה צריך לצייר את קו ה-Max cut כשהרצתי את זה ערך ה-Max cut שהצלחתי להשיג הוא
84 אז נסו את זה בעצמכם וספרו לי אם קיבלתם משהו דומה בתגובות נסו שלוש שכבות אולי ארבע נסו
לשנות את המשקולות בין הצמתים ותראו איך זה משנה את התוצאה יש הרבה ניסויים מעניינים
שאפשר להריץ עם qaoa עכשיו זכרו לא מובטח שאני מצאתי את הפתרון הכי טוב
האפשרי אנחנו יודעים שזה פתרון טוב אבל בשביל הכיף אני מאתגר אתכם לנסות לנצח אותי תראו אם אתם מצליחים לקבל משהו
טוב יותר מ-84 לסיכום qaoa הוא אלגוריתם מאוד דינמי
ויש הרבה היוריסטיקות ועוד הרבה מה לחקור הוא נותן הרבה מקום ללמוד דברים חדשים
על תחום האופטימיזציה באופן כללי היה הרבה עבודה לאחרונה בתחום האופטימיזציה כפי
שמעיד כל מאמרי ה-arXiv שפורסמו לאחרונה באינטרנט על qaoa או אופטימיזציה ומה ש
ממש מגניב זה שסוף סוף לא כל המאמרים האלה הם מאמרים תיאורטיים תיאורטיקנים עבדו וחקרו
qaoa במשך שנים אבל עכשיו גם האקספרימנטליסטים מצטרפים כי סוף סוף יש לנו את החומרה
כמו המעבדים של IBM שמסוגלים להריץ הרבה מהניסויים האלה אנחנו עוברים מהמרחב הדמיוני
לעולם האמיתי וזה מאוד מרגש כן עדיין יש הרבה עבודה לעשות ועדיין יש
הרבה שגיאות שאנחנו צריכים להבין איך להתמודד איתן אבל אנחנו מתקדמים מהר ואתם שצופים בסרטון
הזה אם הגעתם עד לכאן אתם מסוגלים להריץ את הניסויים האלה בעצמכם בבקשה לכו לנסות להריץ ניסוי
של 100 qubit משלכם וספרו לנו איך הלך עקבו אחרי המחברת ותהיו בידיים טובות ואם
יש לכם שאלות או נתקעתם אל דאגה כולנו הרגשנו ככה או היו לנו אותן שאלות כשהתחלנו
ללמוד את זה תעשו כמיטב יכולתכם ספרו לנו אילו שאלות עולות ונתראה בפעם הבאה
[מוזיקה]